هنالك المئات من سيارات الاسعاف التي تنقل
للاسف جثامين القتلى التي يتم يعني
اخراجها من تحت الانقاد في التغطيات
والاحداث الكبيره يكون المراسل الميداني
هو الوسيط بين الحدث والمشاهد الصوره على
ارض الواقع وما يسحبها من مشاعر مهما كانت
دقيقه في وصفها لكن بالنسبه اليه تظل
تجربه خاصه عمار الهندي مراسل العربيه في
الاردن كان في مقدمه المفدين الى تركيا
لتغطيه الزلزال وشارك سابقا في تغطيه
الحرب الاوكرانيه والمعارك الليبيه وغيرها
لكنه يصف مشاركته في تغطيه زلزال شرق
المتوسط بانها تحديا مهني مختلف تماما عن
مهماته السابقه احداث وقصص انسانيه نقلها
عمار الينا بدقه عبر شاشتي العربيه والحدث
لكنه عاشها وشارك فيها خلف الشاشه هذه
التجربه يشاركها معنا اليوم عمار الهندي
ساعه في البنايه هذه البنايه ولكن من
الجهه الاخرى تم اخراج سيده
عشرينيه على قيد الحياه هنالك مدفن في ارض
فارغه في على مسافه تقريبا 40 كيلومتر من
انطاكيا هنالك تدفن ضحايا الزلزال يعني هي
لم تكن مقبره هي كانت ارض فارغه وخصصوها
لدفن ضحايا الزلزال محمد عمار كم احتاج من
الوقت كي انسى ما شاهدته هنا يعني كان هذا
التعليق على منشور لك على مواقع التواصل
حدثنا لماذا كتبت هذا ومشاهداتك العينيه
في زلزال تركيا لا هو عموما الصحافه اللي
بيغطي حروب او ازمات او كوارث
وانا هذه هذا الشيء عشته بعد تغطيه معركه
كييف يدخل في مرحله كوابيس اولا يعني خلال
في المنام يبدا بمرحله كوابيس في حرب بعد
التغطيه بدات معي بعد اسبوع تقريبا بس
ابشركم موضوع الزلزال بدا اليوم يعني انا
اليوم استفقت على كابوس له علاقه بالزلزال
وهذا بحد ذاته متوقع بالنسبه الي لانه
اعلم انه عقلي الباطن فيك كثير من المشاهد
في كثير من الالام في كثير من يعني صراحه
حسره وغضب واحيان كثيره عجز لانه لما تفكر
فيه هو ما الذي حدث الذي حدث انه ملايين
الناس الساعه اربعه وثلث تقريبا فجرا
الناس نيام ساعات نوم ضرب مناطق واسعه
زلزال مدمر
كل الناس هذه اللي كانت في منازلها اصبحت
تحت الركب والمناسبه التحدي الصحافي كان
كبير جدا لانه انت تحتاج ان تكون دقيق
وتراعي مشاعر الناس يعني رغم ان رائحه
الموت كانت في كل مكان لكن يصعب عليك ان
تستخدم مثلا كلمه رائحه كريهه يصعب عليك
حتى لا تجرح احد يعني انت كنت الصحافي
يكون محاصر بالفعل بانه يكون مهني يكون
ملتزم بخط المهني عاطفيا ما بقدر ابين
ولكن في كثير من الاحيان يعني كنا كنت
اكون على الهواء ومعي ضيوف وحالتهم يعني
الحاله التي يتحدث فيها مؤلمه للغايه فعلا
كنت اتعمد انه انا اكون عكس الكاميرا لاني
اشعر في لحظه انه قد فعلا ابكي
وانت تغطي ميدانيا على المباشر كانوا
يطلبوا منكم السكوت والصمت عشان يسمعوا
اصوات تحت الانقاذ ينقذوها كيف كان شعورك
في
يعني احدى النساء قالت لي انت ميت حي انت
في القبر
لكنك حي ولا يسمعك احد لديك ابنتك الحامل
ثمانيه اشهر
وزوجها تحتها هذه الانقاذ نعم نعم في
المكان الذي سمعوا فيه صوت صح
اللي بيحاول الدخول اليه
شوي ريحه قلبنا